finally tonight before we go you might
remember that a little over a month ago
I brought to your attention the single
most urgent crisis of our time Russia
has lost contact with a satellite full
of possibly mating geckos they were
trying to observe their mating
activities in zero-gravity but after
just a few orbits their pods stopped
responding to Mission Control it was
terrifying now you may remember that in
response to that we launched our famous
hashtag go get those geckos campaign
uniting all fans of Astro reptilian
fornication from across the globe and
soon after we launched our campaign it
seemed that we were victorious
we even released a web video announcing
the good news Russia has regained
communication with their interstellar
automobile
oh I remember those days such pure
distilled joy well it turns out I may
have been a little premature because the
satellite landed earlier this week and
Russia had a tragic announcement to make
Russian officials say five geckos that
were sent to space have died No
do you know I would ask for a moment of
silence but that's frankly not enough in
honor of the five brave geckos who lost
their lives please join me in five
mournful flicks of the tongue okay okay
I want answers now I will answers how
did this happen apparently they froze to
death because of equipment failure at
the bright side
fruit flies on that same mission
survived look it's a I don't care
about the fruit flies I only care about
the frozen quizzes listen up in that
shuttle there were four females and one
male and we sent those geckos to have
sex in space not because they were easy
but because he was hard
this is devastating and these brave
horny space reptiles deserve a dignified
send-off those geckos may not have been
able to speak English because they were
Russian and they may not have been able
to speak Russian because they were
geckos
but I am sure that they could understand
the universal language of music so with
that in mind to help me honor their
memory singing their hit song say
something please welcome a great big
world we're all going to miss those
horny little lizards
but let's remember they died doing what
they loved in space anywhere I
would have followed you and I know that
right now right now they're up in heaven
right up there see something I'm giving
up on you they are having high-pitched
sex on the ceiling of God's bedroom
ah
Oh
you
give up
thank you so much for watching bye
by my deep thanks to a great big world
please please do join us next week good
night to you say something
for
say something I'm giving up on you say
something
you